[Musik]
wien die hauptstadt österreichs berühmt
für ihre architektur und geschichte ihre
kultur und musik den walzer und
natürlich das wiener schnitzel die
metzger der stadt verraten gerne welches
fleischmann für ein echtes wiener
schnitzel braucht kalt ist junges rind
ist fett los praktisch wertlos und ist
ganz ganz weich und das original wiener
schnitzel entstand vom vom milchkalb
also das ist es ist mager und es ist
weiter als wir
die bekannteste wiener adresse für das
berühmte schnitzel ist das restaurant
figl müller ein familienbetrieb chefkoch
markus brunner dreht hier jeden tag
dutzende schnitzel und weiß dass es auf
die richtige vorbereitung des fleisches
ankommt also zuerst wird geschnitten und
dann wird vorsichtiger geklopft
weil eben kein flash ist extrem heikel
hat sehr viel wasser bei sauber junges
kalb ist und gerade beim klopfen muss
man extrem aufpassen dass man wirklich
nicht die fassung zerstört weil wirklich
sonst das komplette wasser raus gehen
würde und die schnitzel dann nicht mehr
so schön so viele frische eier golden
aufgeschlagen und feiner semmelbrösel
gehören ebenso zu den wichtigen zutaten
eines wiener schnitzels das kalbfleisch
wird leicht gesalzen und den griffiges
mehr getaucht
anschließend in der masse und danach in
den semmelbröseln wenn sie größer wenn
es nur vorsichtig angedrückt nicht so
stark nun wird das fleisch in
butterschmalz gebraten
dabei ist das wichtig das schnitzel
ständig in bewegung zu halten damit das
gleichmäßig braun wird sobald eine
goldene färbung erreicht ist das
schnitzel aus der pfanne nehmen und das
fette abtropfen lassen eine lite
variante wäre zum beispiel mit raps oder
sonnenblumenöl geschnitten raus zu
packen wir verwenden butterschmalz guter
tipp ist auch ein bisschen gemischt
damit sonnenblumenöl
das hat den vorteil dass wenn ich zu
hause sitzen raus packe die ersten
schnitzel werden schön aber dann hast du
eben diese schwarzen punkte drinnen vom
pool von butter schmalz weil ich das
butterschmalz dann leicht verbringt
typische beilage zum schnitzel ist ein
kartoffelsalat bei viele müller in dem
konto für eigene kartoffeln die von
einem nahen bauernhof kommen und
regelmäßig geliefert werden
chefkoch markus brunner hilft gerne mit
denn mit
[Musik]
zurück in der küche laufen die letzten
vorbereitungen für das wiener schnitzel
wie viele portionen jeden tag serviert
werden das bleibt viele müllers
geheimnis man verlässt sich auf seinen
guten ruf
die geschichte des restaurants beginnt
1905 und lebt mittlerweile in vierter
generation in einem buch erklärt die
familie ihre rezepte in anschaulichen
bildern das wiener schnitzel ist
natürlich auch dabei
[Musik]
wer kalorien zählt bevorzugt vielleicht
ein wasser aber weißwein passt am besten
und dann heißt es in wien guten appetit
[Musik]